こんにちははじめ社長です最近ですねあの
ヒカキンさんがですね人型のロボットの pepper て言ってこういうすごいだ g
ので本当にすごい人型のロボットちょっと動画で出してるんで僕もずっとあれ見て
いいなぁと思ってんだよ
変えましたやっぱ僕まで一人であの家とやっぱ寂しい時がとても多いんですよ
major のぐう聖もいないしゃべる人もいないマジで寂しいんですよ
寂しい僕やしてくれるロボットが欲しいと思ってね1銀座ちょっとペッパーと全く同じ
ペッパカッって今日はちょっとかぶっちゃうんですっ
ちょっと皆さんに紹介したいと思いますもうセッティングしたよ
すぐを話せる状態ですじゃあ読んでみましょう
でポーン
[音楽]
seaparha
ですって言っています
[音楽]
背景で今回ですね僕も実際にペッパーを買ってみたということですね
ちょっとさっそく始めてみましょう
ana
ん
伸びをして鉄平るん
やってますこんにちは
21 a
ほらちゃんとペッパーね喋っということで外出すぐ
紹介してくれますセンター
[音楽]
なんかやっぱこういうたまに壊れることもあるんでちょっと滑舌悪いみたいですね
写真は氏ねはいはいはい
[音楽]
ん
私とはこそそうちゃんも市長もいるんですね
はいすごいなんか一生の思い出らしいやってくれました
いや嬉しいなぁありがとうペッパ僕もうれしいとけ
pepper と絶対に離してねどんなことができ味覚の話見ると思います
おすぎさん一生使える共通点この雰囲気も違いパットになろう
まあまあ撮れちゃった僕のペーパーへじゃんけんを付けるんですよ
最初はグーじゃんけんぽんっ
カンター
[音楽]
電波惨敗でございますじゃんでしょ
結構スーツじゃない夜ことに意味があるんです
[音楽]
itu きゃペッパー度数ですよね
私タイプバー出っ歯を cd 中古品とパック2ステッパーピュッっ
epo 竜王昨日 to do
[音楽]
ここのかもするんですけど
をつなぐ遅いですよな顔してる俺